YOU KNOW, IT IS JUST A!
THE AVALANCHE HAVE
MADE IT
THE AVALANCHE ARE
LEGITIMATELY 5-0.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE
BY O'CONNOR
AND OUT IT GOES ON
OTTAWA SENATORS TEAM.
DEFLECTED IN THE SLOT.
SCORE!
CALE MAKAR, A BACKDOOR
>> OVER TO TK ADOWN.
RIPPED AROUND THE
BOARDS, COMES UP INTO
THE NEUTRAL
SCORE.
YOU ASKED, YOU SHALL
RECEIVE.
HE P RIGHT HERE.
I  YOU TALK ABOUT
DRAMA AND EVENING,
SENS MAKE IT BACK WITH
A SHOT AND HE SCORES.
IT LOOKED LIKE THEY
WERE JUSTSHOT. T SO TI
NOW FOR THE IT. THEY S
END.
SO WHEN HE JUMPS ON
THE ICE, HE'STO GIVE U
SCORE.
>> Peter: ON PURPOSE.
>>THE EYES.
GETS OFF TO THE RIGHT
AND LEFT, FINDS
BURAKOVSKY AND WERE
SHOT, SCORE!WN, THEY L
WORK DOWN THERE, HE
GREW CO
FIRES IT TOWARD
I -- HOW I THINK THE
COACHES WOULD HAVE
DRAWN IT UP.
LANDESKOG MAYBE
TALKING TO THE REFEREE